wir haben es eben gerade gesehene bei
der bahn geht nicht viel voran
jetzt ist ja dieses wetter seit gestern
nichts neues warum bekommt man das jetzt
nicht langsam in den griff
ja wir haben heute nacht wieder
zahlreiche erkundungs und räumungs
fahrten unternommen auf den strecken die
einsatzkräfte der deutschen bahn die
arbeiten wirklich mit hochdruck an den
strecken insbesondere an den strecken
die zu unseren haupt relationen wie wir
es nennen sein haupt fernverkehrs linien
zählen dort versuchen wird schneemengen
eis von den schienen zu bekommen das ist
tatsächlich nicht so einfach denn es gab
wieder starke schneefälle und
schneeverwehungen und das ganze bei
strengem frost sie können sich
vorstellen dass das nicht so einfach ist
starke schneefälle schneeverwehungen die
wird es ja vermutlich auch in den
nächsten tagen noch in weiten teilen
deutschlands geben rüstet man jetzt
dabei der bahn irgendwie auf was machen
sie um dieser situation jetzt herr zu
werden damit auch die pendler und alle
menschen die reisen müssen
an ihr ziel kommen ja wir haben unsere
bemühungen verstärkt diese hauptstrecken
im fernverkehr tatsächlich schrittweise
wieder befahren zu können das sind die
achsen über die orte wie berlin münchen
hamburg hannover köln
das ist derzeit unsere hauptpriorität im
regionalverkehr heute morgen gab es zu
betriebsbeginn starke einschränkungen im
großraum hannover und bremen aber auch
noch im nördlichen nordrhein westfalen
da sind wir noch nicht wirklich einen
schritt weitergekommen ebenfalls großen
beeinträchtigungen thüringen
sachsen-anhalt und sachsen also großer
fokus liegt gerade derzeit auf den
fernverkehr und im regionalverkehr sind
wir der meinung dass es wahrscheinlich
aufgrund der schwierigen
wetterverhältnisse ehrlich noch ein paar
tage dauern wird
also das ist nicht unbedingt ein
optimistischer ausblick für die nächsten
tage frau brücke wären gemeinsam auf
diese fotos schauen denn wenn dann mal
ein ece fährt auf den betroffenen
strecken dann kann es da drinnen so
aussehen her die menschen quetschen sich
in die züge wenn dann mal einer farce
corona regeln abstandsregeln kaum mehr
einheit war wie bewerten sie das
ja es ist natürlich verständlich dass
jeder der nach hause will auch jetzt
wenn die strecken frei und wenn die
ersten züge wieder rollen
da unbedingt mit einsteigen möchte wir
verstehen dass das soll jetzt ein paar
tage wo das nicht möglich war wir sind
trotzdem der meinung dass unsere
fahrgäste sehr besonnen waren dass sie
sich daran gehalten haben ihre fahrten
zu überdenken ob die reise wirklich sein
muss auch unter corona gesichtspunkten
reisen ja viel weniger als üblich
wir haben eine auslastung von 10 bis 15
prozent im fernverkehr
wir haben großes verständnis für all
diejenigen die solche bilder natürlich
eher ärgern das können wir
nachvollziehen trotzdem unsere
zugbegleiter unser zug chefinnen und
chefs wir sind an bord
darum bemüht die fahrgäste zu verteilen
auf die ganze länge des zuges um
wirklich alle mit abstand voneinander
sitzen zu lassen
auch heute werden einige linien wieder
frei werden und auch dort werden die
fahrgäste so gut wie möglich verteilt
werden also das ist ein bedauerlicher
einzelfall
diese fotos die wir da zu sehen bekommen
haben aber wir bitten um verständnis wir
bemühen uns dass so etwas nicht so oft
vorkommt
ein bedauerlicher einzelfall da muss ich
kurz widersprechen wir uns liegen
nämlich tatsächlich mehrere fotos dieser
art vor
es ist ja auch die aufgabe der bahn
dafür sicherheit der fahrgäste zu sorgen
auch in zeiten von chaos und schneefall
wie wollen sie diese fotos des menschen
dicht an dicht sich in den zügen drängen
das zu corinna zeiten jetzt in den
nächsten tagen verhindern
ja ich habe schon gesagt dass wir
schrittweise versuchen die hauptstrecken
wieder zu befahren werden mehr züge
einsetzen können sie besser und so
strecken befahrbar sind dann wird es
nicht dazu kommen dass nur ein in
einzelne wenige züge unterwegs sind
sondern dass wir näher kapazität auf die
schiene bringen können je besser wir
daher unsere strecken befahrbar machen
desto weniger wird es diesen run auf
einzelne züge geben daran arbeiten wir
habt